I may be a group of myself in my own  soul like  if this is how I die trying to attain  this what a glorious death so I signed  my life away I literally my parents were  in the crowd my family was in the crowd  but I signed my life away like this if  this is how I go to Sago but what a way  to die what a way to go out but guess  what  if I'm prepared to die  I'm prepared to kill so in that fifth  round I found a new  level to my fighting spirit that I never  knew was there I tapped into it and I  was just I looked like I was fresh from  the first round and I dropped it was the  most knockdowns in a title fight I  dropped them so many times in that last  round and I almost finished them at the  end like literally maybe another three  seconds it would have been over but the  time right now and the referee pulled me  off him and saved him but yeah I meant  that I really meant that because wow  what a what a glorious moment that would  be